now that's a [ __ ] bonded
greeting some podcast Ville its
Wednesday the 26th of February it's
almost over the guest today is the Queen
miss Chelsea skid wall what's up what's
up with you man
dude I'm just having to be here I'm sore
sore as [ __ ] been working out pretty
hard the past couple days
why what's going on we're going it's
like girls are we're gonna Hawaii in a
month and it's like a [ __ ] countdown
clock for me to get in shape and be
looking good we're going with Stevens
family so you know I've been [ __ ]
around the past year in marriage just
packin on some pounds not working out as
hard and I need to look good so I've
been doing some hardcore workouts the
past couple of days I got a little bit
of time left so what is the Hawaiian
extravagant middle middle March with the
whole family yeah you like this family
they're cool they're very nice it should
be interesting to go on offense I've
never I haven't gone on a family
vacation a really long time he has a
very normal family like I come from a
dysfunctional family his family is just
like they're just like nice normal
people hanging out together
yeah vacations together yeah no one's
getting drunk and crying like it's it's
good vibes good so you're married well
yeah I did yeah but sometimes that
person makes you a lot better you know
that that family influence is pretty
good to have but uh no I was just
thinking about the other day I thought
about you a lot cuz we work together in
Tempe we have a smokin six shows and I
just want to tell you that you and
pressed me more than when I thought you
were gonna impress me really yeah you
really impressed the [ __ ] out of me
that's a feature act like you were a lot
better than I thought you were gonna be
like I've only seen yet yeah at the
store doing bits and pieces but I got to
hear you you know it's really weird how
I judge comics I could just listen I've
been doing it for that long but you know
this
scene in The Sopranos when Christopher
Moltisanti brings Ashe music and he's a
captain that's good music and she's like
that sucks and you think the guy's being
arrogant after somebody's been doing
something for 25 years they know what
the [ __ ] that's going on I could hear
like it here you know I've been trained
to hear up to the last minute I know
when you're bombing I know you know I
know when you control them when you
don't say anything to let them settle
but you were phenomenal
you were you exceeded all my
expectations and if you're really
looking to be a [ __ ] stand-up you
found your calling I think Wow thank you
because you made me think about a lot of
things you made me think about a lot of
things I call in justices towards
comedians but they're in justices
towards comedians but comedians also
have to get balls to do it you asked me
something
you said did you have a lot of hard
times trying to get work when you were a
feature act absolutely the truth of the
matter was and I'll say it right now the
truth of the matter was that when I
started featuring happy after 2000 I had
already been on the road for ten for
nine years like dick nut had already
been on the road like six years but had
been a regular at the store for like
three years so my confidence is really
up so here I am trying to feature and
the excuse for not following cuz he's
gonna blow your [ __ ] doors out was I
was too dirty instead of just saying I
can't follow this [ __ ] I can't [ __ ]
that he's been rehearsing for 20 minutes
for the last three years at a place well
he has to follow Paul Mooney and Eddie
Griffin and then you'd actually what do
you think is gonna happen in that room
in Grand Rapids Michigan in front of 220
people so after 2000 I had a really hard
time getting feature work nobody wanted
to follow me too much [ __ ] work
Richard Jeni stepped up to the pump he
just said don't say [ __ ] and I'm like I
could deal with that say anything else I
want
say monkey punch you in the [ __ ]
vagina anything I wanted to say just
don't say [ __ ] he was one of the rare
guys then Rogen stepped up to the part
but besides that there weren't too many
people because when you're dirty okay so
if I haven't if I go hot there and I
start throwing Heat and I'm saying [ __ ]
if you go up there for a [ __ ] telling
me he's gonna say well she's gonna say
[ __ ] before mean it's gonna lessen the
intensity of my Fox that does all
excuses and guess what I've given myself
those excuses myself guilty as charged
talk [ __ ] you go up there and you
don't worry about who's in funny you
don't give a [ __ ] you go up then you
worry about yourself if you sit back
there and watch that comic and let that
comic get into your head you're losing
this battle if you look behind the
curtain and see people with white hair
like I don't know that was a young comic
and I'd see people white there I panic
for it was always the crowd this is just
about you you know what if she says [ __ ]
you go up then your [ __ ] has to be a lot
better that's it that's it
but there's so many taboos to that
question that you asked me and I
couldn't answer you that day because
people can knock on the door you know
you really can't get into a conversation
hmm but those are the taboos of being a
dirty feature that nobody'll [ __ ] work
with you because there's some people
would just listen if you go up on stage
and start talking about the fetus I'm
gonna bore the baby that's not funny
no it's like you try the shot oh yeah
yeah you're trying to burn them out
you're trying to really burn them out
they could have just stayed home and
watch the [ __ ] movie don't [ __ ] with
cats you know I just don't watch don't
[ __ ] with cats and get the press by
myself but there's people who actually
dirty and they got something [ __ ] say
no if it's about their vagina or their
[ __ ] when I label myself when I call
that book when I tell them I'm the
headline if Chelsea goes on stage and
goes well something funny happened to me
on the way here and lost
you rip your clothes off and put a
sparkler and your [ __ ] and you shoot
octane flames at it and if you do that
the 19 and a half minutes I better think
of something to follow I admit it seems
an Uncle Joe better run for the gas
station a gasoline and dousing himself
and light his feet on fire do something
yeah that's what that's why you hire
that feature act to make you work a
little harder to make you remind you
that you just don't want to go up there
and just do your thing I won't look at
that feature act I want to bounce
something off her I want to work off her
and you were very good thank you
we got into Park edge right that's what
I wanted to tell you no I appreciate
that and like it's great going with you
because I really feel like I could do me
because you know I've opened up or
featured four other comics and in the
past like so the first time I opened for
a comic was Anthony Jeselnik uh like
five years ago it was at Largo I'm so
excited to do it
he was one of my favorite comics at the
time I still really like him but I used
to be a lot darker back then and I was
like I'm gonna do like all my dark jokes
and I got it I opened I got like five
applause breaks in ten minutes like you
know as the opener like they [ __ ]
loved it I was so dark and like it was
like incredible and then after that he
was like a knight you know nothing
against him but he was like you can't
open for me again and I was like so
disappointed and like sad I was
depressed and I was like damn like I
thought this was like I thought I did
great and he's like you're too similar
to me you can't do that and I was like
really heartbroken and you know I didn't
open for anyone for a little bit and
then Bobby started taking me out and he
would say you know you have this you
can't start off so dirty you have to you
know so I would add some I would add
some fluff in and you know some of it
would just be like [ __ ] just like
just you know just to start off easy and
then get into it but like going with
someone like you it feels so good as a
comic to just be yourself to just do you
to do what you want to do and what you
shine at and like I really appreciate
that you allow me to do that or anyone
else you know that you let people do
what they want to do and I truly feel
like I could go out there and I'm not
worried about
what you're thinking just as long as I
said you often do a good job but like
that I'm not being policed and I don't
have to be nervous and I can relax it's
like it's it's the best
I don't like okay you gotta remember I
got thrown out of Catholic school I went
home and my mom said to me there's two
ways to do this this your way and
there's my way I'm gonna let you do your
way for as long
once you [ __ ] up it's my way so I
learned to do it my way right now I'm
not gonna change even even in my married
life I love my wife my wife knows she'd
better not [ __ ] to have a call to
come he's still looking for me don't
ever ask me what time I'm coming off my
wife knows that oh he isn't it's not
like a control thing it's just I don't
know so when it comes to rules I'm up
big on rules yeah
all right so if I'm not big on rules why
would I am Pete rules on somebody who's
working with me
I had a gift I had a gift that I met a
guy named Joe Rogan who told me go up
there and light them on fire there's not
so many people who tell you that mm-hmm
there's not too many people that's the
religion of comedy somewhere along the
line people get that religion of comedy
confused yes now we're at this now what
different situations also people paying
thirty five bucks for a ticket I want
you to be you know yeah I'm from the old
school
I want the MC to do a good job I want
you to go out there and level them and
set them up for me and that's it you
know I don't think I've ever told
anybody not to do it joke because I
don't have the balls to I don't like the
balls unless it's like a joke that
you've been doing for he is hmm and it's
like it's time to retire this
[ __ ] yeah
and even then I just won't talk to you
Tom Walker's if nothing has happened to
you and he is how interesting of a human
being
you know material is based off what
you're going through either God so when
I see a person do a joke for three years
you telling me y'all you did nothing
that has happened in two years I don't
care whether you shot a special not that
material should still be held to but you
should be giving me some more from time
to time I want you to kill mm-hmm I want
you to do those whatever so you look at
twenty minutes set you're gonna film
Ingle six new minutes in there yeah
you're gonna firming GLE it s in the
word mangle means one minute here three
more minutes of good stuff mmm
two minutes here and then two minutes at
the end you know I dam that work yeah I
mix them with the other stuff I hit it I
hit them bushes yeah how to become a
sniper
how to hide in bushes how to throw this
joke in between these two and it didn't
work boom now you close that gap up you
didn't lose anything
you know so that's what you learn along
the way yeah I would I could never go up
to someone and say don't do that jokin
mm-hmm
unless it's just something like I'm
trying to think back if I have but no I
like women opening up for me mm-hm
because a lot of high percentage of
people that come to my shows are women
who bring their boyfriends to be nice to
her it's like you know I'll be taking
you the [ __ ] see cher in New York you
know and the guy comes along yeah don't
let see [ __ ] share in New York at some
[ __ ] play not really but if Bon Jovi
isn't a singer song in the beginning at
least I get something out of it these
things wanted dead or alive after that I
can take another bullet make believe
them having a good time you know yeah
that's why I like to mix it up I like
women in front of me I don't want it all
three guys if I can line up so women
feel [ __ ] lonely enough now I gotta
make you feel lonely I think I hear 40
to 90 minutes of dick stop that's not
fair the women a that you know yeah I
like mixing it up yeah and I really try
to connect with the women too I mean
like I'll tease the guy sort of but I
really try to connect with the women on
everything so it's like
you know so we're having an experience
as well everybody's having a [ __ ]
expert
yeah I know but like so you know I know
that you I normally like love doing
crowd work but I know that you know you
prefer just to do jokes only and not to
do crowd work so I was like [ __ ] I can't
I was a little in my head about it I
think I can't do it I can't do it just
stick to the set and it was totally fine
but I just find a way of delay I need to
some some comics you know they just look
straight out and they don't like look at
anyone I have to like connect with
people and I'll like deliver something
to someone so like I just found a way to
make it work but just all right yeah
yeah the people in the front rows yeah I
look at people everywhere the problem
with talking to audiences on the road
mm-hmm
you know how it is at the store it's
kind of taboo or that like that's number
one tab or whatever unless you're Rick
unless you're rich you know but I know
like there was one of the guys come to
the store he used to rent at tonight's
show he used to do a lot of off the top
stuff and they would always put him up
at 9:15 and [ __ ] like that but when you
get to hell a rule number one is stop
talking to the [ __ ] audience hmm you
know that was a little number one in
1990 when the industry came to see ya
stop talking to [ __ ] audience you
know this industry they don't want to
see you talk about yeah so I lost that
then I stuff I don't do it I'm really
good at it yeah ten years of my life
that's what I did I had nothing right
material I had eight minutes up from the
rest was talk to the audience yeah when
you get to the Comedy Store that [ __ ]
don't fly
Betsy sure they'll go for that [ __ ] you
know and then were you the one who told
me the story about opening for Kinison
know who was oh maybe that was Josh wolf
he I think went to Texas and open
kinnison and he had like five minutes of
material and did 30 minutes of crowd
work and everyone was just like hating
him the whole time like booing him and
throwing but he just kept just like
talking to like one person and beyond
I know it's weird it's just weird so
that's why it's not that'll like it
Late Show you can't talk to you they're
drunk yeah you caused a wall these are
things you learn as a host when you're
hosting these are things you learn as a
feature this is what experience comes in
the 8 o'clock show Bob never than the
ten o'clock show and that twelve o'clock
show no stop talking to go out there
machine than that [ __ ] that's why the
midnight shows they like they ask me if
you want to do a midnight show in Tempe
[ __ ] no because first off you don't
allow me your material mm-hmm you don't
know if you did that joke or not it's
horrible it's horrible everyone's
[ __ ] drunk I know everybody's drunk
yeah and it's like a beer and every
minute that goes past five like goes
past midnight
it's a worst [ __ ] show it's the worst
show in America so that's why I rather
not [ __ ] dope yeah so 10 o'clock
talking to people at 8 o'clock seven
o'clock talking to people at 9:30
telling people was two different shadows
you know so these are all little things
you learn you pick up along the way no I
never thought about that you know that's
why I hate working clubs that run late
Oh icons are only I get the ten minute
late I get to hold the door for five
minutes there's no people on line but if
I'm doing a 9:15 show and we start that
show at 10:00 I'm not coming back to
your club hmm because guess who that
gets put on me mm-hmm that's 45 minutes
that's one extra minute I gotta work
harder to get them because they've been
standing on line in the best never
standing on the shitty weather you know
they wouldn't they couldn't do coke
outside they couldn't Bombay whatever
the [ __ ] they're doing they couldn't do
so now I gotta work a different angle
yeah so that's why I like places that
run their clubs I like them on time yeah
one of the late shows I went to the
bathroom when you're on and there was a
girl who had like alcohol poisoning in
the bathroom on the ground sitting on
the ground throwing up in the toilet she
had to be like taken out and I was like
damn I've never seen someone that drunk
at a show but I cuz it's a Late Show
she's been [ __ ] drinking all day they
get together at 6:00 yeah I don't know
they started six it's cute yeah it's
like who's partying the art for a comedy
show don't you want to hear the material
yeah no yeah but I guess some people do
from people you know what happens that
you go to a concert and you walk that he
walked out and his people barfing they
timed it wrong yeah but that feels
different to me a concert cuz you're
just kind of like you know we need a
really process you know what I mean
you're just kind of like I feel like you
could be really [ __ ] up at a concert I
guess it depends on how you take in the
music yeah it's always something [ __ ]
weird so when you came in here you uh we
keep a current in here yeah yeah we
tried it and this was something that was
really I talked a lot about a lot about
it I thought he wouldn't get convicted
really yeah yeah I thought rape is very
hard to prove especially when you have
women protecting you like if you get
women attorneys [ __ ] women turned
vicious on women you know it's it's ugly
were you trying to keep your client out
of jail but women against women that's
the worst fighter ever is so I knew that
it was gonna be down there's gonna be an
uphill but they got him you know he
[ __ ] over a lot of people everybody
know about it I don't want people to
think that nobody knew what was going on
yeah everybody was in on it you know and
then you came in and blew bye-bye with a
bombshell [ __ ] story that he whacked
awful funny when he came what did he do
well I only remember one time and it
wasn't in a poll I never saw him come
into it we're talking about Harvey
Weinstein right for those of you who
don't know who we're talking about he
came on the floor on the carpet did he
get dizzy or anything with you know it
was like no no I just saw him come on he
came onto the carpet and just left it
there
he kept talking feelings nothing
happened I it that time it was like the
last time I ever saw him and it was like
I get down okay all right so you get
here the year is 2013
six I'm 26 you have to try I I'm hot I
moved to LA I want to be an actor you
know stand-up I had been doing some open
mikes in New York but came out here you
know for the whole thing and the first
weekend I got here I did a photo shoot I
was living with a Russian supermodel at
the time and she was like you have to do
photo shoots it helps you with your
career and I was so dumb and naive I was
like okay but I I today I'm like how the
[ __ ] is that gonna help me you know I
see these girls who waste their time
doing photo shoots on their [ __ ]
Instagram and it's like why you write a
joke you know what I mean like why you
[ __ ] getting dolled up and spending
$500 on hair makeup and doing a photo
shoot like that
I don't know anyways it's fun sometimes
but so I did this shoot with this guy uh
this photographer who was very good did
a lot of like sexy photos and he was
like oh you have to meet this producer
odd you know he did it I think it was a
perv I think he just wanted to see me in
lingerie
it was a like lingerie [ __ ] again I
don't know how this shows that was funny
but so he goes I got this producer I
want to introduce you to he'll really
like you he ended up producing requiem
for a dream which was one of my favorite
movies growing up I had it on VHS I was
so excited to meet him and so I've been
texting with the guy he goes come meet
me right now I was like okay so I met
him for coffee after the shoot it I was
like oh my god this is like all
happening so fast kind of vibe so I'm
hanging out with him we're having coffee
and he's like you're so funny you know
who would really like you Harvey
Weinstein and I was like Harvey
Weinstein he was like yeah he is like I
could introduce you like he loves
meeting young actresses and I was like
okay so a couple days later I'm [ __ ]
meeting him at the peninsula and I'm
thinking oh my god I've been in LA for a
week I'm already meeting Harvey
Weinstein I'm having a great [ __ ]
week you know I'm doing LA right and I
get there I walk into the lobby and he's
in the in the bar with like two female
assistants and they're drinking coffee
and
stuff he's like let's have the meeting
upstairs I'm like great you know I
figure he needs privacy you know he's
Harvey Weinstein like you know he
doesn't want to have a meeting in front
of all these people people are gonna be
coming up to him I think nothing of it
we go up in the elevator we're in the
elevator and he looks over at me and he
goes how old are you and I was like 22
and he goes no you're not and I was like
26 he goes that's more like it
so we get up to the room we're hanging
out and I'm telling him about myself and
he goes I want you to write a sitcom for
me about two girls living in LA and like
dumb dumb idea but at the time I'm like
okay you know he's probably just
spitting out what I want to hear so then
he goes in the bathroom he comes back
he's in a robe and I'm like okay he
might be getting ready for a shower it's
time for me to go and then he's just
like can you give me a massage
I'm just like I'm so bad at massages I'm
not good at them so he gets like a
little annoyed and then he's like and
then he just takes his dick out and
starts jacking off and I'm just like
sitting there like uh like there wasn't
much of a transition in between that and
I didn't say anything cause like to me
like this first time like I wasn't
outraged like it was almost like funny
to me like uh okay you know and then he
was like um so we just jacks off and i
sat there kind of in shock and then he
was like right that and then he comes I
don't remember that particular you know
rum zoom he came and then he was like
okay write that pilot for me and I was
like okay and then I just left and I
didn't see him for a while he texted me
a couple times but you know I it kind of
just like nothing happened so I don't
really think much of that you know I was
like that it was more like that was
weird I wasn't like that was I was
outraged at first I was I was just like
what the that was a weird [ __ ] day
you know what I mean so a couple months
go by and I ended up going to the Cannes
Film Festival I was dating a studio
executive for Paramount and he took me
with him to Sundance - can it was very
fun and we see Harvey there
you know he's like all over and he was a
K like come by uh come by my hotel like
tomorrow afternoon for lunch and I was
like I'm not going up to your room again
and he was like he's like no no no we're
just gonna have coffee downstairs and I
was like okay all right so go there he's
downstairs in a meeting and he's like I
forgot something upstairs and I was like
okay I'll wait down here he's like no
and just come with me and there was like
an assistant with him so I was like okay
like maybe this is gonna be okay so we
get we go upstairs and then he starts
getting weird and he's like trying to
he's doing weird [ __ ] now to his
assistant when I'm just sitting there
and I can't like he's trying to you know
make her like kiss him or something or
do something like that and I'm like all
right I gotta go and he said no no no no
and I'm like no no it's fine I'm gonna
go so I'm gonna believing I see him like
the next night out at a party he said
come sit with us the guy I was kind of
dating we are all like hanging out
together it was fun it was no big deal
we party hopped around we went to like
clubs and [ __ ] a couple months later
then I see him in LA and he's like
texting me to come back or maybe it was
like a year later or something
he's texting me to come back and I was
like uh no I'm not gonna come back cuz
at this point I know what the deal is
and he's like no no it's not like that
I'm gonna get you an audition so I don't
see him he gets me an audition for this
movie what was the boxing movie with
Jake Gyllenhaal south something southpaw
so he gets me this audition for southpaw
someone in his off oh I had a meeting
with someone at his office
they're like make sure you call us after
the audition you know to like seal seal
the deal kind of thing nothing ended up
happening with it maybe I didn't have a
good audition and uh and then like you
know a couple months go by
I like sent him a stand-up tape looking
back it was so [ __ ] bad you know like
those first stand-up tapes you get I
can't believe I sent that to him
not that it [ __ ] matters now but he
was like I loved that YouTube thing he
did he was like he was like you know
work on your half hour I'm gonna get
everyone in town in a room together to
watch you and like you know watch you do
like a half hour or something he you
know promising me things so you know
trying to get together with me and then
finally he he sees this movie don't
think twice Mike Birbiglia 's movie The
Improv movie um and he's like he's like
come by dependent so I was like no I'm
not gonna come by and he was like no I
just saw this movie I'm thinking about
turning it into a series this is your
world let's talk about it he's like I'm
having drinks with people on the roof
people you should meet and then I'm like
[ __ ] and you know a Boyce inside me was
like don't go but I was like I don't
know at this thing I was like I have to
see I don't know I was dumb I look back
and I feel bad for my younger self that
I you know [ __ ] dumb so I get there I
go up to the top floor where everyone's
supposed to be for drinks he's outside
the elevator he goes we're going
downstairs I was like no no no no no I
thought we were going outside he was
like we are we are we are but I forgot
something guys here she's come with me
and I'm like no I'll wait here and then
he does like the dick like thing when
he's like like kind of like
condescending like I'm dumb like no just
what are you doing like come downstairs
and I'm like okay okay
you know I was like nervous and then we
go down there and he said come sit with
me on the bed I was like no I don't want
to and I have like an attitude this time
like I was [ __ ] done with his [ __ ]
and I'm like sitting on the couch and
then he walks off into the other room
comes back completely naked and I'm like
I'm going and he goes no no no no come
over here and I was like no I'm leaving
and then he grabs me like this he goes
just stand next to me in front of the
mirror and he pulled me made me stand
next to him in front of the like long
bathroom mirror and he [ __ ] jacks off
and comes all over the carpet and then I
grab my purse
and I left
and I like got my car and was like
hysterically crying and I was and just
like my life changed after that day cuz
I just never made a dumb mistake like
that again and like I get all of that is
like all of that is crazy like I look
back and I'm like how could you be so
stupid but I was I don't know I don't
know what I I'm an addict like I'll do
the same thing over and over again
expecting different results like I'll
put my hand on [ __ ] hot stove like
five times before I'm like okay I keep
getting burned so that's like basically
the gist of what happened and then you
know a couple years went by and all this
stuff started coming out and I felt like
really emotional about it and everyone's
like come forward come forward and I
paused on it for two days I called up
someone at the Washington Post who was
writing a big article about it and I
told her my story and then I was a part
of one that all of those like little
articles all these different news
sources picked it up and while all of
that was going on when it first happened
I felt like very emotional over it it
felt like it brought up a lot of trauma
for me and I was like a wreck like I
just like said then I just stopped
talking about it and people would always
you know since then for the past two
years people have been messaging me
about it or maybe the past four years I
think now or three however long it's
been going on for I've been messing to
me trying to get me to talk about it and
Twitter I never wanted to talk about it
again and I never like cuz I just felt
for one embarrassed - I didn't want to
like bring up the trauma again but this
morning when I saw that he was guilty
and in jail I felt like a little bit of
freedom that I could talk about it today
on the pod you know but like I don't
know that's basically it ya know hey
let's take this yeah be but now let's
say you were to run home that afternoon
and call the cops and said I just went
over to Harvey's I jerk he jerked off
and come upon me they would have written
up a report mm-hmm and you would have
never heard
again how many think how many girls you
think that happen that in Beverly Hills
in LA yeah I don't happen to you just in
a week yeah
think of what he was running with him
what he was playing with I thought he
would get acquitted or beat it and then
write a book about the girls that did
sleep hmm who in Hollywood did sleep
with him like that that would be his
next move to really say a [ __ ] you know
Hollywood did sleep with me I mean today
who doesn't deserve this Academy away
I'm sure there's so many other people
honored I heard yeah there were but
here's what to add to this like you know
I love you to death yeah but you're a
woman in the world
yeah saying your first rodeo Oh in it
yeah in New York City trained [ __ ]
mafia club danced yeah I came from that
world so this wasn't as shocking to me
until what a third time when it just
wrecked me but here's the other thing
I'm thinking about like this is why I
hated that desperado feeling like
there's really no six succeeding here
because it does make you do things like
that if he got one woman a day they go
up there the odds are in their favor
three or whatever suck his dick yeah
oh I'm sure it was a weekly we're gonna
suck his dick but it's gonna go from
three to four woman a week if he brings
one up there every afternoon what if it
brings one up to every night yeah to a
party you know the Annabelle score you
know I mean when it comes to Hollywood
all bets are off because this just could
have never happened then they were else
mm-hmm except here where you go back to
a party and he rear aims you mm-hmm it
was just too much yeah it is too much
but this could only happen here yeah
this could only happen in this type of
like agent sent you to me with him yeah
I this really big producer a separate
guy set me up at a meeting with this
really big production company who made
every like awesome comedy that I grew up
on
and I had a meeting with a development
executive and I walked in there and he
goes are those real tits and I was like
yeah and I thought this is a
professional meeting and this was in his
office with people like walking around
on the other side of the glass and he
goes stand up do a little spin I want to
see her body I was so [ __ ] shocked
that that happened that felt like you
know like I've had like millions of
things like that happened in my first
year here and then it like broke me and
something snapped and I was like never
again and I'm a little grateful in a way
because it kicked me into high gear and
I've never worked [ __ ] harder after
that you know and I was like I'm doing
the dumb girl thing where I think if I
have a meeting with someone and
something gets handed to me because I'm
cute like it's like no do the [ __ ]
work like it's not like I wasn't doing
the work but it was like a mindset
switch you know it's [ __ ] crazy yeah
it's like you know girls being like
always handed free drinks and you're
just like one of those dumb girls you
know fast life and then like reality
sets in and it's like okay I can't live
like this anymore and like be a part of
that like mentality and scene of people
who operate like that you know what I
mean it's not just girls like if Harvey
Weinstein was gay and I invited straight
guys up there yeah there be hundreds of
straight guys like it's the you think
your dreams come true Bona yeah it feels
like you know I know I'm from New York
I'm smart but like I could be you know I
I was so dumb you know it felt like I
was right out of [ __ ] Wizard of Oz
like what huh
like I don't it's weird it's almost like
I don't know if it's like denial or like
just hopeful that something else this
isn't it it's crazy the mystique oh I
didn't see the mystique of Hollywood
until I saw never Neverland that's what
I got it Finding Neverland yeah Michael
Jackson thing yeah because you know you
take two people from Simi Valley where
were the parents
from hardworking and Americans you know
and then Michael Jack the steps into
your life mm-hmm
next thing you know do you want to go on
tour well you know I could see me saying
hey you want to go to Tempe that's one
thing bring your husband and bring
everybody on the [ __ ] floor you want
and then you know to see how they got
caught up who would think Michael
Jackson uh molest my kid yeah Oh do you
mind if he sleeps in the room I mean
other kids are gonna be in that too and
your kids coming up to you on please
please daddy please daddy knew like I
guess so you know I mean it you get
caught up people got mad at the parents
and I got a clue upset what I want I did
too but you have to really think about
what goes on here how it goes into your
psyche the bottom line is if you move
here you're not prepared for this delete
you up and spit you out
that's a horrible horrible horrible
business and there's a woman you gotta
be on top of your [ __ ] game every day
and you gotta do my Clemenza told
whatever you gotta stop guys like they
should have stopped Hitler in Munich
first move yeah first disrespect mm-hmm
whoa before we even go any further you
say something like that again I'll smack
in the [ __ ] yeah you stop the whole
thing changes because this is not a
tower this is not a town where people
accept responsibility now you become
difficult to work with
totally which light that's the term oh
you're difficult to work with why cause
I wouldn't suck your dick because I
wouldn't let you say to me nice ass
mm-hmm cuz I wouldn't let you say come
in let me spank in he ask real quick
nobody's watching if you speak up for
yourself in this town for people who
don't know you become a term that's
called difficult to work with yeah
that means the director could say to you
you look stupid in that blouse and you
have to accept it were you being from
Jersey but go tell your mother
my dick and he goes yeah and then you
know but now you're difficult to work
with and when you go to your agent and
your agent goes what happened and you
know he told me had nice tits I told to
suck my dick well you should you can't
tell you know JA Kojak amazi to suck
your dick well I just did I just did and
three or four people gonna go shame on
you
shame on you whatever you [ __ ] name is
the Chelsea Hotel but telling jackal
jackal amazi to suck your dick but
there's gonna be one guy they don't
[ __ ] good for you now I'm gonna put
you in all my [ __ ] movies yeah
because that guy's a [ __ ] Punk
thank God you told that [ __ ] and
that's a problem that we don't have yeah
yeah when we come here with green we
want to do good mm-hmm
you know your parents are breaking your
balls what's going on out there I just
sent you another hundred for the rent
yeah well I met with George Clooney last
night we did annoy you with Lucy Liu
yeah he's gonna put me in his next army
movie [ __ ] you know you gotta that
pressure kind of so it does listen and I
tell people all the time I did The
Longest Yard I drank the kool-aid hmm I
drank the kool-aid there was a couple of
months that I drank the kool-aid in what
way I know I didn't I believe that more
things would have happened in my career
I thought that I had moved up a notch I
really drank the kool-aid and I and then
it was tough to accept and what pissed
me off was where I was from guys like me
don't drank the kool-aid mm we see it
for what the [ __ ] it is and ever since
that I'd never drank to cool it again I
remembered that before this whole thing
of comedy and acting yeah and movies and
this whole life that I'm a man I'm a
husband and a father and you have to
respect me from that perspective that
acting stand-up [ __ ]
you talked to me the wrong way you're
going on a [ __ ] window yeah because
it just doesn't
and I did it like I without a director
one time there was tremendous and now I
just go at him if I don't agree and I'm
not saying I'm hard to work with I what
I'm saying his own taste [ __ ] talk to me
too right away just because you got a
little hat apparel on your jacket the
tattoo of a [ __ ] sailor
with your sleeve up you know there's a
pirate director I've worked with you
know yeah I've been on a set well lesbo
that's confused military haircut yeah
with will Chinese lesbo next to her and
they're real artistic cuz they take a
picture of a cigarette burning in an
ashtray you could suck my dick with your
lesbo attitude I'm the Captain Kirk
because it's [ __ ] enterprise you
understand me yeah so get the [ __ ] out
of my that's all of them they come from
all direction yeah one of the first
people I ever worked for one of the best
directors I worked for is the girl from
Mary with children Oh Katie Siegel she
direct no Christine Apple yeah the other
one that the the neighbor's wife Oh Ted
she directed me in MADtv asked the
colgar so really yes she was the first
director she was phenomenal
Marcy no she was a lesbian in real life
ah but that I did 10 projects after that
where the lesbian is smoking like out of
a [ __ ] French cigarette and you know
she comes over to you and orders and I
would tell him take a look at my flavor
take a [ __ ] hike and you should have
seen their faces like I was okay to
about 2002 and then I started seeing it
for what it was and I was still polite
and then I have to long this shot I just
won a war because I got lied to for
years I got leaked we're gonna hire you
for this movie there's no money this
time but you're gonna fall off the
building you gotta be there Sunday at
6:00 you gotta bring your own
dry-cleaning
you got to stitch yourself up and we're
gonna hire you on the next one and then
they do a next one and there's nothing
fully and you bump into the guy around
and he makes you leave like he doesn't
know you
yeah I can't tell you how many times
that happened yeah that well I
sacrificed my life for three days I
turned down economy Stonegate $15 to do
your stupid short film and then once you
sell your short film and you get money
you don't use me now you go you steve
Schirripa
but when you needed me for the mob scene
you all over me when it was for free now
that you have money you don't pay me so
everybody has to pay yeah like after
2000 or something like yeah but it only
pays 100 a day listen it's your dream
isn't it when you kill you when you
approach with this movie this movie is
paying scale now it's paying a hundred a
day this is your dream that's your
problem
mine this is how you want to portray
your dream but paying act 100 hours a
day in them doing a shitty job and
you're gonna wait you get all the
[ __ ] money go get all the financing
come back
well I'm known I've done a thousand
projects that were do this once in 3 I
remember doing a [ __ ] what's those
things you do for free that you it's
like me saying to you for respect mmm I
still remember doing a spectrum Urschel
for somebody on a Friday night when it
was [ __ ] freezing and they didn't pay
us so you had to do it on Friday night
at 10:00 at some cemetery what look like
the cemetery because his buddy dug a
hole yeah and it was me another gangster
and we'll we just finished throwing the
body in the hole and we're about to dig
it up and I go to him go inside and get
a lighter for the cigarette and he goes
in this is a true story guys guy goes in
and the battery's dead because we left
the lights on and it's like don't get
stuck in this position you see his
batteries so it's two gangsters digging
up a body and then they realized the
battery's dead because the lights I did
that spec script that guy [ __ ] told
me that he had him the company his
brother-in-law do you know they shot
that [ __ ] commercial with the same
casting director who called me for it
for free and even the guy that did it
with me call me and he goes Tommy you
just you're not watching the [ __ ]
whatever game yeah
saw that and now was it there was like
I'm done that's hot yeah in the morning
for free and then when he got the
financing he used to other mafia actors
that's yeah I got so the stand-up world
that's a complete different mind [ __ ]
wait till you touch into the acting
world yeah the acting world is
completely different they'll tell you
whatever you need to hear yeah a short
film I worked at this you normally tell
you how many movies I did that you
already had the movie so you already had
the movie sold your brother works at
Paramount them years old and all sudden
you get it added an awesome I got a call
hey you don't even be a YouTube they
could put my movie on me to you like
what happened to [ __ ] CBS yeah oh my
cousin got fired I work for free for 11
days driving to Simi Valley or some [ __ ]
I've been burnt tear down sometime yeah
it's like yeah or like people pumping
you up like you they want you for
something and it's like you came to me
with this it's so excited and I'm like
okay cool and then you just never called
and it's like what was the point of
[ __ ] just blowing my head up like
that like why do we begin with and get
me all excited and then like a week
later nothing happened yeah the stand-up
world is one [ __ ] armpit of a world
and then you get into the acting world
which is even worse in a way like I
don't like it on you know like we
discussed the beginning you know people
act like you're gonna sit down you're
gonna [ __ ] look me in the face and
tell me all those years
not one security guard saw a girl leave
Cosby's trailer hmm with a legs dragging
you won't look me in the face and tell
me that that's fine
you want to look me in the face and tell
me about that listen how he won't seize
a piece of [ __ ] yeah people been doing
that in Hollywood fears they'll continue
to do it even though there's a meet to
act because it's like drugs there's
always a market for it you know if me
you your husband Lee Joe Rogan all of us
get together we go we're not working
Johnny's comedy club
there's always gonna be one person who's
gonna work Johnny's comedy yeah you can
think of hell so our mission is fun you
know I'm sayin yeah so our mission is
come is not complete this you know he
went to jail today
I mean they reprimand them the whole
thing that your mind bars this [ __ ]
still [ __ ] it's terrible that way
yeah I wonder if he just threw the
walker and was like alright I don't need
this anymore
walking with the [ __ ] Walker he's
like [ __ ] this like you know for the sob
story yeah
I'm not yeah I am really glad though I I
stopped following like the story you
know the whole news story of everything
going on but like when I it's weird it's
like but when you hear that he he was
guilty and acquitted
it's like oh I don't know it just like
makes you kind of like breathe easy in a
way like I don't have to like I don't
know it felt like some big secret before
and now I'm just like alright yeah he's
not gonna do 20 years yeah but but when
he's locked up it's like oh I feel like
now if I say something like it's not
gonna matter no like it's not you know
there there is still that little part in
me that's like so you know like I was
saying like all these like news people
kept like emailing me they would hit up
my manager wanting to talk to me and I
didn't want it I had more [ __ ] that
would pop up on Google for my name cuz I
didn't want to be difficult or she's a
narc or like she she's difficult she's
gonna make a big deal about something
like I I still even after everyone
saying how [ __ ] up it is it's like I
don't want people to look me up and be
like oh she's one of those [ __ ] girls
you know dude the Moonies lived in my
neighborhood there was a [ __ ] Moonie
like property in my like coldest AK
there was like a lake and a [ __ ]
Moonie house in a Mooney Church you're
coming to church of Reverend yeah yeah
Reverend yeah yeah yeah how weird is
that I don't really know what I didn't
really understand
that was it was just like that's the
Moonies and I didn't know what that
meant I didn't know it was still around
yeah I just made it as an expression I
haven't heard any is the ponies yeah was
that all mostly on the East Coast are
all over was a cult I'm the hello yeah
it was some kind of like it was like a
Korean church like and it was the moon
yeah I don't know they all live together
in this one house and then a girl who
was in my grade was a Moony and she got
like an arranged marriage after high
school I think to like another one but I
still don't the real thing that really
shocked me about this whole column and
you have a great sense of you know what
did you even laughed about it like when
he jerked off you thought was kind of
funny and no yeah but it's like it I
mean like again you're not in that
mother Teresa I was a stripper before
that you've seen the world by the balls
yeah I'm not judging you or anything I
love you guys I've jacked off in front
of me before that just friends and I sat
there and laughed with my girlfriend
look at this [ __ ] it you know yeah
but it's funny that you felt something
you felt cheated you felt dirty
you felt assaulted in the way like you
felt that you felt it but after that
last time the third time I went back I
was crying in my car I got back to my
apartment I was cry was hysterically
crying on my hands and knees on the
floor of my apartment that day like it
like it like rocked me and it wasn't
only like that it was like everything
that happened leading up to that kind of
thing and then it was just like this
thing that like changed in me but it was
for the best again because it's like I I
would not be working as hard as I was
today if none of that happened well just
they just yeah right forward to show you
what yeah I believe everything happens
for a reason and it was time to start
being you know it's not being dumb I
mean like you know I think I was like a
bit of a dreamer in a way like my head
in the clouds
you know like yes I am from New York you
know I am street smart in a lot of ways
but I think I just had that whole thing
of like moving to LA and it's like you
know like city
dream City of Hope like kind of vibe I
think I was just like kind of an idiot
just like wow like maybe that's like how
things happen I don't know I like you
know I feel like that's probably like an
immigrant who moved to [ __ ] in New York
back in the day or like from Ellis
Island or something and was like this is
you know and probably got some [ __ ]
handed to them you know what I mean
right no no I get what you say it's a
woman I like I said I didn't drink to
the kool-aid till 2005 2004 mmm I had
been here seven years and I knew what it
was and then after I drank the kool-aid
and came down from it
it was like it took me by the ear to
recover from it seriously a long time
that was the end of my drug use like
once I came to terms with what this was
that was the end of my drug use that was
the end of living like a weird lifestyle
I settled down and I knew what I wanted
I know who I was gonna avoid yeah I know
I wanted around me you know there's
people that come to this town with a
dream and a scan mmm and there's people
that come to this town with dream and
work ethic there's two different types
of people that come to this town and
eventually you see the people come in
with a dream with a scam mm-hmm it's a
dream and a scam but every move they
make is a scam to try to accomplish
their dream but it never does what the
hard work does never you might pass me
by a little bit but in the long run it's
a long run it's a journey
[ __ ] not a it's it's a marathon you
know so that's what I always felt that
there's a lot of like I told you before
this I love new meet new me love being I
know I love like be I love being a comic
and saying new me like when I was a
comic my third year like how are you
doing comedy three years in one scene
whether it be Denver a Boston Charlotte
Atlanta you know now you're up there
with the open mic is you're allowed to
talk
you like to set the table and then young
girls come in like you that's new mate
and they come in and they go up on stage
and we all laugh at his jokes cuz you
wanna [ __ ] right standing ovations you
know I'm saying the first night oh my
god I didn't know is this funny yeah
hilarious
let me help you right yeah yeah yeah you
know and that to me was like yeah I
probably did it myself I don't you know
I can't you know that's how you learn
not to be creepy is by being creepy and
getting every yeah oh I've went to
coffee bean with a certain paid regular
a couple of times in my first couple
years at the store because they thought
I was funny and just wanted to help me a
little bit
now I avoid that guy right ya know it's
so it's it's it's just and that is even
a bigger like all that [ __ ] bothers me
because when you do drugs when you
[ __ ] if you're hooking you know
you're doing something that is on the
other side of the fence
weird things are gonna happen to you
because you're on the other side of the
fence
but when you really believe in this
whether it be stand-up acting writing
directing then people [ __ ] with your
dreams it hurts a little more yeah I get
that [ __ ] hurts a little more you know
so I'm happy that they threw that far I
never liked Cosby anyway so I could give
me a sh talked about him I could give a
[ __ ] about Harvey Weinstein is seen in
his movies and his people yeah oh my god
those people any why don't you look
[ __ ] good they want me one of them
always or not tell us you know but I'm
happy that uh I studied it from a legal
point of view and I thought he was doing
okay he was doing the right steps the
more longer he took the more witnesses
would disappear what time to describe
the girls you know I know that she ain't
a part a libellus core yeah because wait
a second so he raped you everything he
came back for his party you know [ __ ]
like that that's Hollywood [ __ ] yeah so
he raped you ain't gonna come back to
this party you're from Jersey I ray
be it next time you come to a party to
your three brothers with a stick yeah
yeah so that's why she lost credibility
you when you're an actress and all that
[ __ ] you kind of are don't lose
credibility and I'm sorry to say this I
have a daughter yeah you know it's it's
so hard to prove a rape case mm-hmm so
[ __ ] hard mm-hmm without you know
even with the DNA they could really miss
oh yeah they could miss handle the
[ __ ] [ __ ] in the lab the guy didn't
put a glove on you don't [ __ ] know
you know the BOJ trial the guy took the
blood home why would you take the
[ __ ] blood home with you do you
usually take evidence home with you yeah
well it was getting late that's it you
walk out of the court cry and I shot a
load you got a rip pair of pants
everybody's happy
that's it I mean that that's it that's
basically it so I knew would be an
uphill battle especially from you years
ago
every conversation it's money
how long can he last he hired people
when he fire them that's an old stalling
because the yeah the longer I take the
more you change the story I'm gonna keep
sending investigators to your house tell
us again about the matter August 4th did
you a ritual when I asked you in
September you said you got a red shirt
on well [ __ ] how many times should I
tell this story that's always good on
you you told your story needs a lot
because that's what they're looking for
the trip you up
yeah well I didn't mean that one up
there I meant that his assistant yeah I
don't want to [ __ ] talk to anyone
else again it was a one-time thing and
that was that and then they just copy
and paste it into every other [ __ ]
new source well no yeah yeah I think it
was just embarrassing because you know
you read the thing on everyone Minds
like Chelsea went back several times but
it's like you know I noticed a lot of
big actors it was like they went there
one time in 1997 he pulled his dick out
and they left immediately I don't think
so
I don't think so they probably went back
a couple times or if not they proud I
mean I don't know it's hard to I was
just telling the truth about what
happened
me I feel like other people might have
had a different experience but I felt
dumb in comparison like ooh that does
not look good and that was his rape
playground for those film festivals
right I think I saw I think Rose McGowan
had something at was it Sundance or
something right like that was but yeah
well he's like the king in the film
festival you know like when you eat I
remember I think I saw him at Sundance
and he was sitting behind a blocked-off
rope at a party and everyone trying to
talk to him at [ __ ] can you know he
has the private table with all these
like hot actors and like the studio
executive guy I was with was like can
you introduce me like you know before
all that [ __ ] happened like he was the
[ __ ] man you know like he was like
the number one like keys to the kingdom
guy for like so many people so it's like
you got to imagine how many girls came
here he did that to dad left and there
on to a new life yeah you know like it
knocked him down completely our young
age I just took that what you did yeah
yeah yeah that was just another day in
Hollywood yeah you know just another
[ __ ] Monday afternoon yeah all right
well that's not happening again so
that's so [ __ ]
yeah well I'm happy you got over it yeah
that [ __ ] that happened it happened
before how [ __ ] crazy is that
Barry our week and you meet [ __ ] it's
too perfect
the first week you know and it's like
looking back like I don't know I was
just like wow like I have really good
luck like it was from the most like
sincere place you know it was just from
like a hopeful starry-eyed like you know
I'm sure that happened I'm sure it was
like it's like design that way because I
trace it back to like I'm sure the
photographer dude and the [ __ ] other
producer guy there in like cahoots with
all that you know it's like they're
they're finding people off the [ __ ]
bus load from Russia to like just you
know what I mean like it's like preying
on like the new the the naive you know
the confused the you know I'm sure it's
like it's like a grooming process almost
it's crazy it really is yeah such a
[ __ ] nightmare yeah we'll look at you
now hey you're bad thank you so much
yeah married yeah it's a girl guys
joking awful funny dude no yeah I still
let Steven do it I know he's hoarding
about me being 57 just taking my dick
out of the rope and just jerking off in
front of a young girl that's crazy you
[ __ ] horrible like I would feel
horrible it's mental illness when people
tell me that they'd go get a hand job
somewhere I know you're furious hmm I'd
really you know all that [ __ ] drives me
crazy you gonna use lord louis c.k lost
everything yeah over a hand job because
he jerked off with my two girls yeah in
2003 at the Aspen I don't get it I don't
yeah he went down fast and there was no
strong fellows not that it's interesting
how certain certain people have certain
yeah and some people at someone who
didn't rape anybody
yeah sure you know you just took his
dick out or called you and breathe heavy
on the phone yeah there's no [ __ ] law
against that
yeah can't breathe probably is yeah
that's a scene in the movie happiness
you see that movie oh so good Todd
Solondz movie the guy who did welcome to
the dollhouse it's really good Philip
Seymour Hoffman played that he would
call people in the phone booth I mean
out of the phone book and like jack off
and breathe it's such a good movie yeah
I don't like that shovel is he in the
leaders a good indie movie and no
[ __ ] phone booth this [ __ ] you got
going on that just writing stand-up
husband I'm a chill I don't know just
keeping it just thing really busy
Bobby giving you some work yeah yeah I
go with him I don't know what I'm going
out again with him somebody call you
like three days before it's
he is the most last-minute person ever
yeah so I'm just doing stuff in town you
know doing showcase this week for just
for laughs and ice house and store and
the showcase is just for last where yeah
it's not the story this time thank God
come on yeah in the pendant first other
two ones I did was like the [ __ ]
Improv lab which is the worst [ __ ]
room Westside comedy which is an awkward
I'm just so grateful this time of death
yeah they finally left four years they
wouldn't stop for really four years yeah
well even as a personal that's
interesting so now I would the [ __ ]
Club yeah Stadium yeah like what we had
talked about though you know just like
arranging my set to like please someone
like I'm [ __ ] over it like I'm gonna
do me if you [ __ ] want it cool if not
I don't give a [ __ ] like I just I don't
know it's it's just that whole thing of
like me just wanting to do me with the
material that I want to do and not
trying to like impress someone else but
goal would be for you to go up there to
do new faces yeah that's true that's
what it that's what it's for
yeah so you can't be too r-rated yeah I
want them to show me who you are
we've all come from mm-hmm but don't go
over the top this is a business it's
half and half I'd rather you what's that
expression I don't want you to win the
war but lose the battle mm-hmm zion.t
you yeah I don't know either they like
you or they don't
yeah there's someone when you comes to I
love just relax
I never would I never got invited I was
going to crash now they want me to go
but I can't go I can't go to Canada but
it's so weird how just for laughs
there's so many different you can I get
mad at them if they say no to you no
totally I'll tell you why because this
it's like why don't get the breakdowns
anymore mm-hm I used to get the
breakdown let me tell you that would
[ __ ] get ulcers because when your
agent quality and says hey a row came
out you're perfect for and reality for
roles came out that
four rolls came out that day but the
other three have something attached to
them that you don't know and unless
you're with a good agent
they're not gonna know they're not gonna
call the casting director to say Chelsea
what's the problem with this role for
Bobby well Bobby's good but when the guy
wrote it he really won't wrote it for
Bobby Lee mm-hmm so I'll read your guide
but they really gotta make an offer to
Bobby Lee I'm not gonna get Leon yeah
see your file on the Santee there's a
gist I know that [ __ ] and they're tight
with the thumb [ __ ] I had an AIDS in one
time this is how good he was he called
the director and had him turn an extra
roll into a [ __ ] paid acting role Wow
and he put me in it that's an age that's
a good age I don't like those Dom while
he was up until whatever happened to him
he gotta agent moved to Germany to try
to get the treatment cuz I guess in
Germany had better wow people for the
AIDS or something and I saw him a couple
times at Murray tea he gave me his card
he's done the business anymore but till
this day and that's why I know people
are lazy because I had a great manager
at one time when I first got here I had
a managing that was probably the best
person I've ever dealt with you could
call him within 10 minutes he'd have an
answer he hunt that [ __ ] down at
lunch you know yeah where most people
like we call but then on the office we
left a message this guy hunted you down
you know and it just they don't make
them like that no hole yeah that's sad
why it was a director the name of the
movie was Dickie Roberts there was a
movie with David Spade where he plays
his [ __ ] crazy dude and in the
beginning David Spade has to fight
somebody he has to fight Emmanuel Lewis
or something like that Bobby Slayton is
the referee
me and him head all day and I just walk
out it's like four big black guys and me
in the front and I got like two lines so
the agent talked
director into making that speaking role
Wow do you see what I'm saying to you
yeah you know there's people out here
that jump on it and you know there's
people that don't jump on it when it
comes to breakdowns you don't know all
the variables and for you you don't know
all the variables you have a good
manager Nicole and she's got some clouds
so I think you'll be fine yeah hopefully
you nail it pop to Montreal
yeah absolutely that be great and it's
not another thing coming that's better
yeah totally hopefully whatever else you
got working out yeah yeah I know I've
been waiting for some stuff with some
scripts you know I'll talk about it when
it happens but until then yeah I were
very hard I work very hard but I'm not
gonna you know run my mouth over
something that hasn't happened yet no
but I'm excited and I'm excited to see
what happens this year with some of that
stuff it was fun working with you so
much fun last of the real Mohicans I got
that VHS from McDonald's one time and a
Happy Meal which one the last of
Mohicans isn't that weird
that's it felt like a mistake I was like
why is this in my Happy Meal it was in
the place of a toy I think someone at
McDonald's did it as a joke and gave it
to like a kid isn't that bizarre yeah
what could've been one say give me a
point that's true that's true
yeah happy meal yeah website Chelsea
Skidmore comm podcast the Chelsea
Skidmore show how many podcast you do a
week I do want a week I've been going
for two years sometimes I'll do two if
you know and then just but I released
one a week yeah a [ __ ] camera thank
you so much you were savage and I want
to wish you all luck in the world you
got all the tools you're gonna be a
[ __ ] animal thank you I'll be
tomorrow why not be tomorrow might be
Friday no Fred I want to thank Jeff
don't forget Friday night Viva Las Vegas
myself and bean Del Ray at Treasure
Island one show one night where I there
Sally I'm back Saturday at 11 o'clock of
the [ __ ] morning I'm excited you know
saying I'd love to do nothing till May
20 no March 27th I'm at Santa Barbara
at the Arlington theater so I have I'm
gonna need some dates I'm gonna be
kicking around New York for a couple of
days so that's what's going on right now
and that's not that easy I see some of
you [ __ ] Friday night in Vegas
I'll see the rest of you [ __ ]
next Monday tip top Magoo it's a whole
new month a whole new set of rules
that's it
it's March [ __ ] it was just whispers
two weeks ago you were just jumping up
and down for New Year's and this March
and you still haven't studied your
resolutions so you better get your [ __ ]
together [ __ ]
see you Monday mornings the rest he is
I'll see you Friday night Treasure
Island with my main man Dean Dell rizzi
kick this [ __ ] melee